Hey, David, people often talk about if X wins,
I'm moving to Canada.
What would it really take for you to leave
the United States?
This is a good question.
I mean, remember, so I was born in Argentina,
moved to the U.S. when I was five.
Anytime I want to, I could move back to Argentina.
The economy is a disaster in Argentina.
A lot of the.
It's not exactly a place I would love to be.
From the standpoint of the virus, although
things aren't great in the United States,
in Massachusetts, things are pretty good.
And Massachusetts continues to be, you know,
a good place to live.
In general, theoretically, I could move to
Israel and after a year, I believe I would
become eligible for citizenship, so.
If the question is of the places I could realistically
go and and move to permanently, what would
it take?
I mean, things would have to get pretty, pretty
bad here in the United States and particularly
in Massachusetts, things have to get worse.
We do have a country of 50 states, and the
Scituate living in Massachusetts is very different
than living in Mississippi from the standpoint
of health, education, climate, business regulation,
social issues.
It's completely different.
If things got really bad in Massachusetts
or I believe that they were going to, I would
look at a sort of sabbatical of sorts, not
from work.
I would just work elsewhere.
And depending on the Corona virus situation,
Argentina could be a possibility and Israel
could be a possibility.
Right now, I don't see either of them as places
I would move to in the immediate.
What would it take for me to permanently abandon
the United States?
I don't know.
I mean, you know, my parents live here.
My girlfriend's family is in the United States.
I have most of my relatives are in Argentina,
some in France, some in Israel, some, you
know, different places.
My social life is in the United States.
I have a U.S. based business which I could
run from another country.
But it's certainly easier being here.
It would really take a lot.
And this is why when we hear AU billionaires
will abandon the country if taxes go up, maybe
a couple of them will.
But by and large, people live where they live
for reasons.
And the longer they live there, the more attached
they are to it.
And it would really take a lot for me to say
I'm just leaving the United States permanently.
It doesn't seem something that I would be
likely to do.
Now, that being said, I have said if things
were to get very bad in Massachusetts in the
fall with the virus, would I look to see?
Can I.
Without breaking any rules, can I go somewhere
that's doing well?
Quarantine for 14 days, take a negative test
and sort of just do the show elsewhere for
four months or five months until things settle
down.
Could it be, you know, some picturesque part
of rural northern France or something?
I mean, that sounds amazing.
That is a different story.
But in terms of truly just abandoning the
United States, it's not likely.
And I think we have to be really careful to
take too seriously.
Anytime someone says if X wins, if X loses,
I'm leaving the country, particularly, by
the way, when a lot of the people that say
that often say they would move to countries
that represent what it is they are trying
to avoid.
You'll hear Republicans say if Trump wins,
I'm leaving the country and going to X, Y
or Z.
Well, a lot of those countries, if Trump loses,
rather, or if Obama wins, we heard it.
I'm moving to X country.
Most of those countries are more in the direction
of Obama than what some of these people want.
Really counterintuitive.
And for the most part, these are empty threats
that we shouldn't pay too much attention to.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
join Pakman dot com.
We will see you then or otherwise
on Monday.